[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du débrief du dock
consacrée au documentaire intitulé aco
vide en afrique et quand la nature
reprend ses droits pour en parler nous
recevons aujourd'hui à sergio lopez
président de l' ong à wildlife angel
bonjour sergi lopez merci d'être avec
nous aujourd'hui sur arte france alors
vous avez vu ce documentaire comme nous
est-ce qu'il correspond la situation
vous vous connaissez actuellement en
afrique pire leur déjà bonjour merci de
me recevoir en ce qui concerne
documentaire j'ai été très accroché par
la première partie de ce doc parce
qu'effectivement pour une fois et ça
fait longtemps que j'entendais pas ça on
a une personne donc en l'occurrence une
quelqu'un qui représente le kenya ou à
des services et qui dit qui dit la
vérité sur la pandémie et le braconnage
et la situation des animaux en afrique
alors avant qu'on rentre un petit peu
plus un vainqueur de ce documentaire je
le disais dans l'introduction de cette
émission vous êtes à président et
fondateur de los angeles
angel quel est son rôle qu allissa sa
mission aujourd'hui alors la mission de
wildlife aujourd'hui c'est de protéger
la faune sauvage africaine en danger et
en particulier en s'appuyant donc sur
les rangers et en protégeant la forme on
protège également les rangers c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons mis en
place des formations qui leur sont
destinés tentes pour les entraîner bien
évidemment dans ce challenge important
qu'est la protection de la faune mais
également donc de les équiper et voire
de les accompagner sur le terrain donc
pour être encore plus efficace vous
n'avez pas toujours fait ça donc dans
votre vie qui qu'elle était justement le
le déclic pour vous pour permettre
justement de monter cette ong est de
partir justement formés à ces personnes
en afrique mais dans un premier temps je
travail dans la protections en
protection rapprochée depuis pas mal
d'années donc c'était relativement
facile de transposer toutes les
procédures tout ce que toutes mes
connaissances dans la protection des
hommes à la protection des animaux
sauvages ça c'est le premier point est
deuxième élément je connais l'afrique
depuis pratiquement trente ans
maintenant jetterait de mes guêtres j'ai
été donc guide de brousse pendant pas
mal d'années ce qui fait que connaissant
également les animaux sauvages
et voyant depuis quelques années la
situation dramatique dans lesquels de
cibler les grandes espèces emblématiques
que sont il était de mon devoir
abandonner de réagir et de faire en
sorte d'utiliser mes compétences au
service de la faune sauvage alors on l'a
dit ce documentaire s'intitule locaux
vides en afrique quand la nature reprend
ses droits on a d'abord cru un temps que
en afrique locaux vides avait permis aux
animaux de se réapproprier leur espace
c'est pas forcément si vrai on regarde
un petit extrait et puis on en parle
juste après très bien
[Musique]
en 2020 avec la pandémie de kovy de 19
les nouvelles d'afrique ont été rares
dans les médias le monde ne pensait
qu'au vide et il y avait en afrique
considérablement moins de cas qu en
europe mais quelque chose mérite est
néanmoins qu'on y prête attention les
médias ont annoncé un boom des
naissances chez les éléphants au kenya
les journalistes y ont vu un lien avec
le fait que les touristes n'étaient pas
autorisés à entrer dans le parc ils ont
aussi vu un côté positif au confinement
mais en réalité le qu'ovide n'avait rien
à voir avec ce phénomène
[Musique]
la période de gestation chez eux dure 22
mois en 2018 vous comprenez nous avons
eu de très fortes pluies et les femelles
sont excédentaires était
alors en 2020 nous avons eu ce baby boom
de 106 et les fantômes
d'importantes intempéries cela veut dire
que les femelles ont plus de nourriture
à donner aux éléphanteaux des choses
vraiment extraordinaire se passe dans le
parc national d'amboseli la femelle
patia a accouché de deux jumeaux ce qui
est extrêmement rare
alors je le disais on a souvent entendu
un que coronavirus avait permis aux
animaux de se réapproprier leur
territoire on le voit dans cet extrait
avec les naissances des éléphants qui
ont augmenté un phénomène qui n'a rien à
voir avec le courant n'a virus dont qui
n'a absolument rien à voir donc ça m'a
amusé pour ne pas dire autre chose on va
dire c'était l'été 2020 quand j'ai vu
dans les médias dans les grands médias
français et européen donc annoncé que
les éléphants donc avait augmenté en
termes de nombre d'individus grâce à
l'accord vides puisqu'il était moins
perturbé que les rhinocéros qu'il
s'agisse la namibie ou du zimbabwe
également donc avait augmenté dans honey
dans l'été 2020 grâce à la con vide
parce que man - importunés par les
touristes la seule problématique étant
comme l'a si bien dit de la scientifique
dans votre reportage 22 mois des peurs
de gestation pour une éléphante 15 à 16
mois ça dépend de l'espèce un de la
sous-espèce pour les rhinocéros donc
effectivement un co vie de la commune
qui démarre au mois de mars et des
naissances qui arrive trois mois après
donc grâce à la couv its est
matériellement impossible alors je ne
doute pas que l'ensemble des animaux
dans les parcs nationaux étaient est
certainement surpris
13h58 voire moins de touristes ça change
j'en suis conscient a contrario donc
dire que grâce à la coved ça a permis
donc aux éléphants rhinocéros si l'auto
espèces emblématiques de se développer
c'est tout simplement archi faux alors
si le coville n'a pas eu d'impact
justement sur la vie des animaux en tout
cas il en a eu sur le braconnage
à moins de 10 éléphants ont été tués en
2020 à 34 ans en 2019 et 80 en 2018 le
coc vide a permis de laisser les
braconniers en dehors de tout ça est
loin des animaux oui alors la situation
du braconnage est un peu plus complexe
qu'on aurait pensé là vous citez à juste
titre les éléphants on peut également
citer comme je faisais tout à l'heure
les rhinocéros qui aussi hanté - comment
dirais-je moins concerné par par le
braconnage par contre il faut bien
différencier les types de braconnage en
afrique là nous parlons de braconnage de
type dit mafieux c'est à dire des
éléphants et des rhinocéros ce sont des
animaux les premiers donc les éléphants
ils sont tués a battu paul ivoire et les
rhinocéros pour leurs cornes ces
produits-là donc sont envoyés en asie du
sud est souvent dans les transports
licite et c'est ce braconnage la qui a
été interrompue a contrario à cause des
problèmes économiques générées par l'aco
vide sur le territoire africain ce qui
est beaucoup moins devises puisque moins
de touristes quasiment plus du tout
d'ailleurs
malheureusement donc il ya une nouvelle
forme de braconnage qui n'ont pas émergé
parce qu'elle existe depuis des
décennies mais qui a été marqué ce et le
braconnage de subsistance ou là
malheureusement dont les populations
locales à cause précisément donc des
problèmes matic économique on était
obligé entre guillemets de braconner
des animaux pour manger mais justement
va en parler de ce braconnage de
subsistance vous parliez du braconnage
mafieux et les rhinocéros des éléphants
quels ont été les espèces concernées
justement parce ce braconnage de
subsistance alors donc dans le
braconnage de subsistance ont oublié les
rhinocéros on oublie également les
éléphants en revanche vous avez toute
une batterie
d'espèces qui sont intéressantes niveau
de la viande on va partir de la plus
grosse on va dire du buffle jusque-là
petites antilles au pouvoir au
phacochères dans l'est dans les pays non
musulmans donc vous avez donc une
kyrielle d'espèces qui sont
intéressantes pour les populations parce
que quelque part quand vous abattez un
laser qui fait grosso modo dans les 300
kg vous pouvez nourrir quand même
plusieurs familles pendant en quelques
mois est-ce que vous avez des chiffres
pour justement ces animaux sains la mort
de ces animaux qui ont augmenté pendant
ces deux parades de covin ça c'est une
question fondamentale on n'a pas de
chiffres aujourd'hui et pourquoi n'at-on
pas des chiffres parce que c'est pas le
fait de ne pas en avoir qui est
important c'est la raison pour laquelle
on en a pas tout simplement parce que la
plupart des réserves et des parcs
nationaux ont été vidés alors bien sûr
vider des touristes en haut on en est
conscient mais surtout ont été vidés des
protecteurs c'est à dire que les rangers
dans la plupart des parcs nationaux
n'ont pu travailler tout simplement
parce qu'ils avaient plus de tourisme et
surtout parce qu'il n'y avait plus de
moyens pour les rémunérer c'est ça qui
est grave donc aujourd'hui on ne manque
d'information en manque de data sur
l'année 2020 est un petit peu soignée
2021 à cause précisément donc de
l'absence de ces personnes qui n'ont pas
pu faire de recensement qui n'ont pas pu
au jour le jour suivre l'état des
différentes espèces là on parlait tout à
l'heure de ducobu d'un qui a aussi
provoqué justement une crise économique
dans la région elle même partout dans le
monde tout dormant
amis qui a forcément forcé certaines
personnes à pratiquer le braconnage de
subsistance on va regarder un petit
extrait puis on en parle la rupture
en ces temps de qu'ovide la vie des
éléphants n'a pas changé
les éléphants n'ont pas remarqué qu'il y
avait une épidémie de covin mais il
pourrait se demander pourquoi n'y at il
plus de touristes et plus de voitures je
pense qu'ils demanderaient ça s'il
pouvait parler
[Musique]
mais pour ceux qui travaillent dans le
parc où habite à côté les choses ont
radicalement changé
en ce moment beaucoup de gens sont
renvoyés chez eux limogés dans beaucoup
d'entreprises
j'ai entendu parler du cas d'un
chauffeur qui avait un très gros crédit
il a fini par se suicider
peter saitoti et mécanicien il habite
près du parc national d'amboseli même
s'ils ne travaillent pas dans le parc
lui même sa famille en dépend
directement
avant je pouvais réparer les motos des
gens pendant qu'il faisait leur cours
mais maintenant ils ne peuvent pas venir
l'as monaco donc les magasins et nous
autres mécaniciens en souffrons loca
est ce que les témoignages que vous avez
entendu dans cet extrait sont conformes
à ce que vous vous connaissez sur le
terrain malheureusement ils le sont là
nous avons l'exemple du kenya je peux
vous citer également des exemples en
habit vivent en afrique du sud a
fortiori en afrique de l'ouest également
qu'il s'agisse du niger ou du burkina
faso énormément de deux parcs nationaux
ont été impactés par l'aco vide non pas
par la maladie directement mais par les
conséquences économiques de cette
maladie il faut savoir et c'est
peut-être un problème en terme de modèle
économique mais le fonctionnement du
parc national on va dire à à 80 90 %
donc les entrées de des touristes
correspondent donc justement 80 90 % du
chiffre d'affaires à partir du moment où
il n'y a plus de touristes il n'y a plus
de chiffre d'affaires donc tous les
salaires si vous voulez ne peuvent plus
être versés mais ça ne concerne pas que
les guides ou les accompagnateurs comme
on l'a vu dans le reportage ça concerne
les chauffeurs sa consoeur les
mécaniciens les femmes de ménage celle
qui qui font la cuisine etc donc
à toute une logistique monstrueuse
derrière en parc national que l'on ne
mesure pas forcément et qui a été
salement impacté par l'aco vite ce qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui le grand danger
contrairement à ce qu'on dit encore une
fois les médias n'était pas tant au
niveau des espèces sauvages mais plus
sur les populations à même donc si vous
voulez de faire fonctionner ce pacte
national vous le lisiez un beaucoup
d'africains ont été impactés par cette
crise sanitaire et plus particulièrement
cette crise et économique on parlait à
l'instant du braconnage de subsistance
est ce que les ong comme vous est ce que
les gouvernements africains ou tenter
justement de mettre d'y mettre un frein
non malheureusement on n'a pas tenté
d'abord parce que des ong je parle pas
des de ce qu'on appelle les bingos les
grosses saint-ernel et les grosses ong
internationales mais celles qui ont une
taille comme la nôtre donc nous n'avons
pas la capacité financière si vous
voulez à faire face à une telle
situation ce qui impliquerait de notre
part de prendre en charge des différents
salaires des guides des chauffeurs et
ses terrasses qui est impossible
aujourd'hui on nous on arrive à peu près
à financer nos opérations si vous voulez
de formation auprès des rangers donc
malheureusement on ne peut pas et les
gouvernements encore moins parce que
encore une fois je vous parle des
modèles économiques qu'est ce qui fait
tourner un parc national ce sont les
devises étrangères les entrées a
pratiquement il n'existe plus les
gouvernements locaux sont incapables si
vous voulez multiples raisons de
financiers sergi lopez président de
wildlife angel ont fait une petite pause
vous restez avec nous et on revient tout
de suite après
de retour dans ce débrief du dock
consacrée au documentaire co vide en
afrique quand la nature reprend ses
droits nous sommes toujours avec un
sergio lopez fondateur de lohengrin life
angel alors on parlait à l'instant avec
vous elle fairview lopez du braconnage
de subsistance en afrique est ce que
c'est une situation qui a existé
ailleurs on peut penser notamment en
amérique du sud ou en asie
en aussi certainement en amérique du sud
également si vous voulez donc dans
toutes ses zones encore une fois qui
dépendent c'est ce fameux modèle
économique auquel je fais violence tout
à l'heure dans toutes ses zones où il ya
des parcs nationaux où il ya des aires
protégées qui fonctionne malheureusement
donc en autarcie s'étaient alors d'un
côté il y a des devises a mené par des
touristes et de l'autre donc ces devises
mais sont mises entre guillemets à
disposition des personnes qui vont faire
en sorte que le parc fonctionne à partir
du moment où il n'y a plus de devises la
raison même d'être du parc donc devient
difficile et si vous voulez pour le
gérer c'est éminemment complexe dont
malheureusement de très grandes zones
comme comme en amérique du sud par
exemple dans les zones dans la région de
l'amazonie également donc en inde on a
on a recensé ces problèmes là absolument
alors on le disait le kovy 19 à impacter
beaucoup de personnes justement
économiquement elle dansait dans ces
régions du monde impacté énormément la
population va regarder à nouveau un
nouvel extrait et on en parle après
j'ai du mal à me pencher et a soulevé
des choses
avant les gens s'arrêtaient pour aider
maintenant les gens passent leur chaude
désormais tout le monde a des problèmes
n'est pas pour
les business les médecins les marchands
même l'environnement
locaux vides nous a vraiment gâcher la
vie
alors même si on ne cautionne pas le
braconnage on peut comprendre le
braconnage de de subsistance pour
certaines personnes ça a été une
question de vie ou de mort
compétent et là vous mettez le doigt sur
quelque chose de très important dans
notre doctrine wife angels on a quand on
fait des formations je reprends des
rangers par exemple on leur explique que
ceux qui le braconnage et on décompose
c'est une typologie que nous avons fait
mouche et waldfogel qui est très
importante pour amener cette dimension
de discernement de la part des rangers
et on leur explique qu'il ya différents
différents modes de braconnage
différents types de braconnage du port
conages de subsistance au braconnage
mafieux et c est qu effectivement la
réponse que doivent apporter les rangers
doit être adaptée au type de braconnage
quelqu'un qui vient tuer une antilope
parce que ça fait des semaines et des
semaines qui n'ont rien à manger que sa
famille n'a rien à manger on comprend
tout à fait et dans ce cas là si la
personne était prise sur le fait on va
dire par nos rangers on va expliquer aux
rangers que leur comportement doit être
adaptée à cela a contrario ceux qui
viennent pour braconner d'éléphants du
rhinocéros dans le but de gagner de
l'argent et d'expédier sa en asie du sud
est là le comportement doit être
différent donc bien évidemment que nous
whole foods nous sommes très attentifs
aux personnes malheureusement qui ont
été contraintes pour des raisons de
survie appelons ça a penché un chat aux
directions de survie de braconner vous
parlez des rangers ces personnes que
vous formez justement pour empêcher le
braconnage mafieux qui sont ces
personnes que vous formez et comment
vous les former alors ces personnes
depuis quelques temps c'est là encore
c'est dans notre doctrine nous
préconisons l'embauchent de population
donc issus des villages autour du parc
national c'est à dire on évite de
prendre des personnes qui viennent de
trop loin on préfère travailler dans une
dimension très local et ce pour deux
raisons la première parce que ça
bénéficie voulait à l'économie locale ça
crée des emplois et ça c'est important
et deuxièmement parce que en termes de
culture il est toujours important
d'avoir des gens qui sont issus des
populations locales aux alentours du
parc ça c'est très important en termes
des changes en termes de compréhension
des problématiques et entière surtout de
résolution de ces problématiques donc
voilà qui sont des rangers ce sont des
jeunes gens en général donc nagé on va
dire de 18 20 ans jusqu'à 40 voire plus
des personnes qui bien sûr ont besoin de
gagner de l'argent c'est la première
motivation faut être clair mais par
contre y en a d'autres des motivations
c'est le fait de défendre leur
patrimoine
ce sont des gens et moi ça et j'ai
toujours été très surpris depuis des
années que je les connais
sont des gens très attentifs à leur
patrimoine qui en sont très conscients
qu'ils comprennent que des êtres humains
viennent de tous les coins de la planète
pour admirer des éléphants des
rhinocéros des lions parce que ce sont
les derniers animaux sauvages donc sur
terre et ils sont très conscients de
cela malheureusement il n'en n'ont pas
forcément les moyens la capacité le
gouvernement encore une fois pour des
tas de raisons on n'est pas capable de
les former de les entraîner de les
équiper et de les nourrir donc à juste
titre et c'est la raison pour laquelle
des associations des ong comme la nôtre
donc se substitueront normalement on ne
devrait pas le faire mais nous nous
substituer à l'état aux états aux
gouvernements africains mais pour leur
apporter ce dont ils ont besoin alors
justement vous parliez du gouvernement
quelles sont vos relations avec le
gouvernement est ce qu on vous accueille
justement les bras ouverts alors en
général très bonne mais on va dire parce
que en amont on a fait un choix nous ne
sommes refusé d'intervenir dans certains
pays qui sont très corrompu il y en a en
afrique on va pas faire une brosse une
liste forcément donc nous en amont si
vous voulez on a déjà choisi des zones
dans lesquelles nous allons où nous
n'allons pas et ensuite dans lesquelles
nous allons je me suis fait un point
d'honneur mans en tant que président à
dire à toutes nos équipes on
n'intervient pas sur un territoire sans
l'aval des autorités gouvernementales et
locales j'ai insiste lourdement là
dessus pour les gens qui connaissent
bien l'afrique les l'autorisation du
gouvernement est indispensable pour nous
mais elle n'est pas suffisante il nous
faut également donc travailler avec les
communautés locales avec les populations
les chefs du village pour être également
accepté de ces populations une fois
qu'on a les accords de deux de ces
partis là nous pouvons commencer à
travailler et justement comment ça se
passe est ce que c'est un long processus
ou où ça va plutôt assez vite
généralement non je crois qu'on peut
dire que ça va assez vite on a d'abord
une une première phase d'audit mais qui
est tout à fait normal pour savoir donc
nous on met les pieds d'abord ça nous
permet derrière nous de faire
des labours un manuel de sécurité pour
nos personnels bien évidemment que nous
envoyant sur place on a également manuel
médical qui permet là aussi donc de
faire face aux premiers secours si
besoin il y avait et suite à cet audit
on identifie la menace en corse un plan
de formation adapté en accord avec les
autorités locales et ensuite on déroule
la formation en sachant que derrière la
formation il ya un accompagnement sur le
terrain et certains coachs de wildaf
angel donc accompagne les rangers sur le
terrain pendant plusieurs semaines pour
voir comment leur capacité à traduire en
comportement opérationnel ce qu'ils ont
acquis pendant les formations alors si
les relations font plutôt bonne avec les
autorités locales j'imagine qu'elles le
sont moins avec les braconniers ah oui
ça c'est clair elles le sont beaucoup
moins avec les braconniers donc pour
l'instant donc on n'a pas eu forcément
de problème avec eux mais encore une
fois donc et ça ça procède en amont si
vous voulez de d'audit très précis nous
avons encore une fois des manuels de
sécurité avec des procédures très
strictes pour nos personnels ça le grand
public ne le voit pas quand on annonce
une mission mais nous avons des
procédures très strictes pour nos
formateurs pour éviter effectivement
kiné de problèmes sur place mais ce que
vous ranger sont armés alors ça dépend
ça dépend des zones dans la plupart des
pays africains aux rangers sont armés
par contre ça on a eu le cas donc à deux
reprises une fois en guinée une fois en
république démocratique du congo nous
étions dans des zones où les armes sont
prohibés donc nous avons fait des
formations donc à des rangers 100 ans
alors justement vous parlez de deux
situations qui pourraient intervenir
quelle serait la pire des situations
vous pourriez ou que vos rangers
pourraient vivre sur le terrain or
malheureusement j'éviterai le
conditionnel puisque ce n'est pas quelle
serait la situation mais qu'elle est ou
quelle a été la situation parce que
malheureusement on a déjà vécu sur un
une situation peu particulière nous
intervenant en afrique de l'ouest dans
deux pays en l'occurrence c'est le mali
le pardon le burkina faso le niger est
là si vous voulez en 2020 on à 2019 2020
il n'y a pas eu que la problématique de
l'aco vide il ya une autre problématique
dont on a peu parlé ici mais dont on
parle pas mal dans l'air dans les
réseaux sociaux c'est l'insécurité dodu
au réseau djihadiste et nous avons donc
des organisations djihadistes très
présente dans les parcs nationaux dans
lesquels nous intervenons et la menace
principale donc pour nos rogers a été
précisément ces groupuscules d'ailleurs
il y a un an exactement jour pour jour
nous avons perdu deux de nos rangers
donc récemment formé suite à une attaque
jihadiste malgré toutes les formations
qu'on peut avoir on n'est jamais prêt à
faire face dédia liste on est
entièrement d'accord et là vous mettez
vous mettez le doigt sur un point très
important les rangers sont des
défenseurs de la nature sont des
protecteurs de la faune sauvage en
aucune façon ce sont des militaires
voire des spécialistes en antiterrorisme
s'il y a c'est ce que je dis souvent au
gouvernement s'il y a des djihadistes
des on va dire des rebelles ou des
terroristes parce qu on a des rebelles
en rdc par exemple en république
démocratique du congo
s'il y a des rebelles présents s'est
alarmé de les chasser ce n'est pas aux
rangers de faire ce travail au le ranger
encore une fois est là pour protéger la
faune sauvage certainement pas pour
faire des opérations militaires et
justement à ce que à ce moment là où
vous avez dit boulay les rangers sur
place vous êtes gentil mais ce n'est pas
à vous de vous confronter
malheureusement aux jihadistes mais
paradoxalement lorsque vous dites c'est
moi qui l'ait dit ça
les gouvernements à la limite ils
avaient des rangers sur place il avait
des gens des paramilitaires pourquoi pas
c'est moi qui dit à ces gens là non il
faut surtout plus de rangers parce que
c'est pas leur métier est ce que
justement vous auriez envie de dire aux
états de prendre plus peut-être leur
leurs précautions pour vous éviter ce
genre de situation clairement je dirais
c'est comme à une époque donc
malheureusement il ya des ong qui ont
été interdites dans cette certaines
zones à cause de la sécurité je crois en
mon données même alors je parle des ong
caritatives a pas que pas des accusés ou
iphone jallet autres je crois qu'à un
moment donné il faut tout accepter une
situation c'est à dire que si c'est trop
dangereux
si en effet la présence d' européen
pourrait inciter les déjà 10 à des
attaques voire des kidnappings et
malheureusement il faut accepter de se
retirer en attendant que la situation
soit assainie par les gouvernements
locaux et une fois que la situation y
avait à peu près sous contrôle là les
ong que ce qu'il s'agisse de wildlife
avec des rangers ou tout simplement des
associations caritatives ils adorent ce
que l'on pourra revenir alors vous nous
le dites vous travaillez parfois dans
des situations très compliquées face aux
braconniers face aux djihadistes parfois
mais votre mission c'est aussi et
surtout de sauver des animaux est ce que
vous savez ou bien vous en avez sauvé si
ça peut chiffrer depuis que vous faites
ce que vous faites
non c'est très difficile voire je dirais
même impossible à chiffrer et puis on
n'a pas malheureusement le temps à
consac parce que ça nécessiterait un
investissement en termes de temps très
important ce qui est clair c'est que
quand nous intervenons dans une zone il
ya quand même quelques indicateurs
malgré tout les agriculteurs ce sont le
nombre de personnes qui ont été mis sous
les verrous ce sont les alors là ça se
passe plutôt à naval de notre opération
ce sont dans les grands aéroports le
nombre de saisies de produits on se rend
compte que grosso modo alors je vous
donner un exemple concret dans une
réserve privée de namibie bien
évidemment je tairai le nom parce
qu'elle est elle peut être ciblés par
les braconniers cette réserve de namibie
donc à le nombre le plus important de
rhinocéros de namibie un nombre très
élevé cette réserve affaire est pas là
nous en 2015 parce que elle était
menacée donc par des braconniers alors
bracconi de corne de rhinocéros donc les
braconniers commerciaux de très haut
niveau à ce jour donc nous sommes en
2021 o comme aucun rhinocéros n'a été
abattu par des équipes que nous avons
formés pendant plusieurs temps donc on
peut dire qu'effectivement ça se mesure
mais pas de manière très concrète avec
des chiffres très très précis mais bien
évidemment que notre travail est
apprécié sur mesure sur le terrain oui
avant de se quitter sergi lopez on a
parlé en début d'émission du tourisme
forcément beaucoup de touristes dans ces
régions du monde pour apprécier les
animaux sauvages dans leurs dans leur
lieu là où ils vivent leur état naturel
quel est le message que vous voudriez
faire passer aux touristes peut-être
qu'il aiderait dans ces régions pour
respecter totalement l'endroit qu'ils
visitent et puis les animaux qui y
vivent
ouais ça c'est une très bonne question
d'ailleurs la dame dans votre reportage
d'amendé on a reparlé quand elle a dit
je serais curieux de savoir
comment réagissent les éléphants par
rapport au nombre de vols de véhicules
qui est qui est moindre qu'avant et
c'est moi si j'ai un message à donner
aux individus se seraient aux touristes
ce serait deux messages en fait le
premier c'est de se dire que quand on va
visiter un parc national je conçois que
1 safri coûte très cher galy billets
d'avion il ya toute la logistique nous
tenant sur place ça coûte de l'argent
mais en aucune façon vous n'allez dans
un zoo et si vous voulez comme comme dit
souvent les touristes vers le big five
c'est d'ailleurs voir les cinq plus
grands d'afrique
ça se mérite il faut passer du temps ici
vous ne les voyez pas
vous allez en voir mais si vous ne voyez
pas c'est pas grave la nature c'est
comme ça d'accord il ne faut pas comme
parfois donc je les ai déjà vus des
tories se mettre la pression à certains
guides à certains chauffeurs pour
absolument voir le rhinocéros noir qui
n'ont pas eu l'occasion de voir ou avoir
la chance de pouvoir apercevoir le
léopard dont qu'il vient de tuer un
animal et qui l'a mis sur la branche ça
c'est le premier message il deuxième
message et quitte en corollaire
d'ailleurs c'est à l'instar de ce qui
peut se passer au kenya dans certaines
réserves mais quand vous savez il y a eu
un lieu en fin ou des lionnes quand tu
es un animal de grâce ne vous précipitez
pas de manière à avoir 15 20 35 ans de
minibus autour de autour de la proie
la savane est large les comment
dirais-je les parcs nationaux sont très
étendus soyez curieux avec vos guides
donc fait en sorte de ne pas perturber
la faune sauvage c'est ça qui est
important parce qu'à un moment donné
effectivement trop de touristes peut
nuire au bon fonctionnement des espèces
sauvages bon en tout cas le message est
passé je remercie sergi lopez d'avoir
été avec nous dans ce débris du dock
merci également à vous d'avoir suivi cet
épisode que vous pouvez d'ores et déjà
retrouver sur notre site rtl france à
point et à très bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]